لكننا ما زلنا نناقش فكره تلك الصفقه
الجديده المحتمله والتي ردت عليها حركه
حماس ردت على الاطار العام لاتفاق الصفقه
الجديده والاسرائيليون الان بصد مناقشه
هذا الرد نبحث ذلك مع ضيفنا من الناصره
محمود يزبك الاكاديمي والخبير بالشان
الاسرائيلي سيد يزبك اهلا بك اذا نتنياهو
سيلتقي القيادتين الامنيه والسياسيه في
اجتماع عاجل بعد ساعات قليله لمناقشه رد
حركه حماس كيف تبدو لك المؤشرات التي تسبق
هذا الاجتماع بناء على تصريحات المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين وكواليس الاجتماعات
الاخيره نعم صباح الخير يعني اولا واضح
جدا انه اسرائيل الان ادخلت في مازق اكثر
صعوبه مما كان عليه قبل الرد الذي قدمته
حماس والسبب بسيط انه هناك القيادات
السياسيه الاسرائيليه وخاصه نتنياهو في
الايام الاخيره عاد يعني صعد ال الشجره
عاليا مره ثانيه واستعمل مصطلح جديد يعني
قبل ايام فقط من قبول وصول رد حماس وهو
الانتصار المطلق بعد ان تنازل عن مصطلح
الانتصار حوالي اسبوع عاد من جديد
لاستعمال مثل هذا المصطلح وان الحرب تنتهي
فقط حينما يكون هنالك انتصار م لاسرائيل
الان جاء رد حماس الذي كل يعني كل
المراقبين يسمونه يعني رد ايجابي وفيه
تفصيل تفصيل يعني كبير جدا للمراحل والى
اخره والان وضع الحكومه الاسرائيليه في
مازق جديد ونتنياهو هو نفسه الان في
المازق مقابل الضغوط التي تمارس عليه بشكل
هائل جدا اليوم من العائلات عائلات
المخطوفين الاسرائيليين وخ خاصه ان هنالك
خبر في الصحافه الاسرائيليه يعتمد على
النيويورك تايمز وا وصحافه امريكيه اخرى
بانه هنالك حوالي 30 شخص قد قتلوا من
الاسرى في الانفاق يعني قتلتهم قوات
اسرائيليه مهاجمه او قنابل اسرائيليه
اسقطت عليهم في قطاع غزه فهذا اثار يعني
مشاعر لد الكثيرين بانه عدد القتلى
الاسرائيليين يعني او هكذا يشاع في الاصر
كل يوم يزداد ولذلك الحكومه الاسرائيليه
عليها ان تتخذ قرار ايجابي للمفاوضات اي
حسب يعني ما يقوم به عائلات الاصر وهنالك
ضغوط كثيره في داخل الحكومه والان في
انقسامات يعني واضحه جدا نتنياهو كيف ينزل
عن الشجره هذا سؤال كبير الان يوضع امامه
امام الحكومه الاسرائيليه وحتى الان حينما
تفضلت حضرتك وقلت انه سيكون بعد ساعات
سيكون هنالك اجتماع للقياده السياسيه
والعسكريه دون تفصيل من هم القياده
السياسيه والعسكريه هل يعني سيكون م مثلين
عن احزاب المتطرفه اليمينيه ام فقط
الكابينيت المصغر
العسكري او كابينت الحرب او ان سيكون
هنالك اطراف من الكابينت الموسعه ولذلك
الامور حتى هذه اللحظه يعني ننا ساعات
قبل عقد ال الجلسه الرسميه
للمداولة يمسك بهذا الرد رد حماس ويناقشه
مع القيادات
السياسيه والامنيه والعسكريه اي مخرج
سيختاره باعتقادك خاصه وان هناك اجماع من
الضامنين والوسطاء بان رد حماس
ايجابي نعم واضح وهذه هي المشكله الاساسيه
يعني المجتمع يعني القياده الاسرائيليه
نتنياهو ومن يدور حوله عمليا هم خلقوا هذا
المازق الذي نحن اشهده الان فالسؤال هو
ماذا سيقول بلينكن حينما يجتمع مع هذه
القياده ويشرح لهم يعني ضروره الموافقه
على بنود هذا هذا المقترح قد يكون هنالك
طبعا سيكون هنالك تحفظات اسرائيليه واضحه
جدا ولكن السؤال الكبير هو في جلسه
الحكومه او جلسه المجلس السياسي والعسكري
هل اسرائيل تستطيع ان تخرج وتقول نحن لا
نرفض هذا سؤال الكبير وانا اعتقد يعني من
قراءه المشهد العام خلال الايام الاخيره
الاسبوع الاخير وحتى هذا اليوم ومقارنه مع
موقف حماس الذي وصل انه اسرائيل لا يمكن
ان تقول لا مطلق هي ستقول نعم ولكن نعم
مشروط وتبدا المفاوضات
يعني انا باعتقادي الرد الاسرائيلي الان
سيكون ايجابي سلبي بمعنى انه نعم ولكن
وهذه اول مره يعني الاسرائيلي هو الذي سي
يعني يكون في خانه انه يقول لا ولكن لن
يستطيع ان يقول لا لانه الضغوط التي تمارس
عليه من الداخل الاسرائيل وطبعا كذلك من
الخارج حتى بايدن نفسه حينما تطرق لرد
حماس قال انه مبالغ فيه لم يكن انه سلبي
لم يكن انه يعني غير قابل للتفاوض مبالغ
فيه فممكن التفاوض على هذا ولذلك الان انا
اعتقد انه نحن في مرحله التفاوض التي ست
تبدا اليوم ولكن اسرائيل ولا اي حاله من
الاحوال تستطيع ان تقول
لاك محمود يزبك الاكاديمي والخبير بالشان
الاسرائيلي من الناصره شكرا جزيلا لك